oh my god there's so much [ __ ] in this
game now mm-hmm yeah for those who don't
know this is uh four rundowns removed
from the last time we played it's fully
released um lots of different things
hopefully to make it more fun we have to
start over
yeah what are we starting no this is
totally different other rundowns yeah
this is an unrelated campaign to
anything we did previously
oh you started
six
no that's no no the way it works is like
episodic right so we're in la we're like
in episode six this is what's available
right now it's not like levels and [ __ ]
oh okay yeah the other rundowns are
deleted let's uh let's just get into it
no no power of the sun hopefully from
the kick oh
but that's our thing
the rain is making my spine tingle that
didn't used to happen that's kind of
cool there's tomorrow's nice
yeah
yeah i really love it when we're talking
in the middle of it
oh good
sensory deprivation chambers
all right
now for the good stuff i wonder how deep
we're going now for the sixth expedition
dude i don't know well this is top level
uh this is like
least deep
oh yeah flash flights
looks like we're ready for a roller
coaster
dude that would be
such a scary roller coaster oh my god
just a huge tunnel down into the earth
and you're just like accelerated into it
yeah i would do that
all right
but the floor opens on the way down i
mean it kind of is tower terrorist come
over here real quick there's some new
items we can gather and i think they're
shared
at the end of the match
don't make fun of my spears mr butt plug
look
i'm just
all right i i like this fear i'm jealous
i just wanted to be
all
it does look like you're ready to like
tribal someone yeah fear for the win
what's the range of it
it's pretty long see how far away you
can stab me from
what the hell you are in me wham nah
look if you survive this
you can have a spear
we could have been spartans when we wipe
and go back to the menu
no no no no we're not going to wipe
what's the what's that
button again what's the tag button um
middle note
yeah middle mouse yeah you're right here
yeah
apparently y is cycle weapons that's
scary locked
melter i got a lock melter
oh good that's so good
wait you found another artifact yeah
there was two artifacts in this closet
area there's um a med pack and an ammo
pack in here i don't know if i carry
both
i don't know if it's just the the
setting or what does this look a little
more crisp than it used to oh yeah i
used to play this on low stuff
it looks nice oh it's really wrong too
now oh yeah yeah who's got our scanner
is there anything i do yeah i forgot let
me
remember how to use it around i'll find
them uh we got some through this store
here definitely some bodies uh nothing
in this room with us that i see all the
damage oh fall damage
about that fall damage
did you just walk off that fuselage no
no i jumped off oh
oh cool
your health gone
already uh what are we looking for we're
looking command query hater no matter
wave projector i mean
white 55 dy55 but there's no terminals
in here i don't think
okay there's no there's an alarm oh
there's one up here there's one up here
oh hey there's a terminal cool i never
knew how to use one someone
what do you want to query key white 55 i
think yeah command and then you want to
try and ping it if you can oh i forgot
you can draw you can draw on the map go
away don't do that
how do you move the map okay there you
go
where are you really big go to zone 77
and look for key white 55 what zone are
we in this one
we are in 75 a right now we have a door
to the second door
that door door
that door over there
this door yep
excuse me fear burps there's one right
outside the door but and then another
about 15 meters to the right
that's okay you guys got spears and
lights off all right flashlight's on
guns out
oh yeah i remember this oh this feels
this is much more terrifying
echoes of things running in the distance
yeah yeah be aware there's one
five meters outside this door here
not for long we gotta open the door too
open or do we yell and run at it oh yeah
there it is it's just that one though
the other one shouldn't spawn go ahead
he's doing child's pose yeah that's
chill let's see if this works
he got very scary oh they turn into goop
now oh bye-bye yeah he's gone why can't
i ping enemies you can't ping on an
enemy you can only ping i can't paint
anything over here
i pinged something oh there's a there's
an artifact on the ground over there
many monsters here no he's lying there's
nothing
if you hold q you get a whole like
comma rose thing that you can use oh oh
[ __ ]
oh
oh my gosh oh you're gonna ask for stuff
oh that's that's cool as [ __ ] that's a
really nice list i bet that's for squad
commands when you're playing with bots
yeah he white 55 is in zone 77 e okay
terminal all right so that's it
so we're on our way
over there uh essentially at 67. none of
us are at full ammo you can go ahead and
divvy up that ammo pack right now just
to clear some in that story it's 20 a
chunk right so as long as you've got 20
oh ammo i've only got a
two so here's one for you thank you
watch that light oh yeah no there's
nothing there so are there any in here
no okay
uh we're looking at enemies
directly on the other side of this door
we got oh stairs one on the other side
of the door three clustered 15 meters
away
it's a locked door but it goes to 77b
and a bunch of other zones we don't need
yeah we don't need those oh good i'm
gonna reopen this after you guys get
down here then
why aren't you in there spearing already
do it you're a reminder
debbie
careful how many mark some there's four
total four
that one is
yeah when they're not yawning
there we go good pop
one down that one's yawning
okay
basically if you hear the click that's
assigned to stop
you can you can play off the audio i
hear one off to the left i hear there is
one 20 meters off to the left it
shouldn't be triggered by this group
all right oh
yeah think of your cycles what was it
used to do to sync them up mark flashing
with your flashlight
is that a good thing to do right now no
no no you guys should be able to charge
and run in and you should be able to get
i'm ready
so we'll call the charge
charging three
two
one go good
job that was so in sync all right
there's one
that was a little slow i was right on
the edge of
shooting uncontrollably there i'm gonna
i wanted to build up the tension a
little bit don't edge me so hard
others are on the other side of this
door but this room's clear hey there's a
lock over here can i like hammer the
lock off i have a lock melt oh
why didn't you just try it i don't know
i didn't want to like set off in a lo i
don't know
i don't know i don't know all right all
right we got a bunch
there's about six total in here they're
all kinds of stacked and dispersed in
line all right here we go
so there's that my light's not off or
anything
that's
a 77c over there as well that we could
have it's fine but that's we could've
okay oh god how do we how do we do this
this is gonna be a bit tough uh they're
so daisy changed they're mostly all
gonna go i'm gonna hang back and be
ready to turret in case of emergency
yeah watch out sean this one to the left
over there too i'm gonna think right
here
he might be okay i might be able to just
get the one in single file at the end
yeah
it's gonna be tricky though this is
gonna be
bob we're probably gonna need you yeah
i'm going to hang back and just be ready
to
see daisies
you need me to come up and and smack
some heads uh there's there's two left
after all four of these wade can you
handle both of those i can try with the
spears a long charge up time but i can
try that's true
let's just i might be able to get two
yeah bob you you focus help him i'll get
this one and then
oh there's a seventh i am in uh actually
i should move over just
i forgot it just releases okay we're
good it's okay we're good we're good
we're okay nice oh
all right yeah yeah it died it just goes
after i forgot i can't hold it the
stairs heavy all right it's just these
three here just three here and one
farther down the way but it should i got
the standard
okay i'm on this guy here wait not yet
not yet
i'm gonna move in on the
child's pose yeah i get her yeah okay
i'm in position
i think i can probably just kill him
yeah i'm ready let's do it yeah
two left two right actually
i am gonna go which way are you going
mark left or right i'm going okay you go
leftover
i'm going right with wade is it up top
or down they're separated i don't know
where's the second oh okay here we go
okay one's down below here
hey dude how you doing you gotta pop you
got it oh god it's fine it's fine
get in here stop stop flowing okay thank
you guys
you got this one
all right you're right
i'm charged
oh we're so talented uh room clear
hell yeah dude that was flawless
execution with no chance of failure
there i mean it was very good i really
like this power of the sun
i got it
you guys need to see into tomorrow no no
thank you we need to backtrack the way
we went what is that what door did we
even come through is it the one no it's
not the one wade's at it's over
it's down here yeah it's where i am if
you look on the map
[Music]
yeah this is the intro level to the
whole thing we're doing good guys hey
shut the [ __ ] up
is
two on the other side off to the left a
little bit off alarm is that's like an
alarm okay yeah maybe we think about
this for a minute okay yeah yeah i can
go put a turret at the door we just came
from i can foam this um the other doors
here though i might be able to close
that lead into this that might slow down
yeah definitely do that should i form
the floor or one of those doors
uh definitely a door i will say before
we foam the doors moving forward though
i should probably put my turret on the
other side so that way while they're
trying to break through the foam they
can be getting shot in the ass yeah yeah
whatever watch them come from a
completely different direction
yeah it seems very likely watch them
come
i usually do there's websites for that
nowadays well no time like the present
opening well there was some nostalgia
for the past there could be a good
future there is no opening
oh god
i'm not there i'm not there
keep you on your toes
fine this is fine uh i think you can
scan and like ping their bodies right
mark i'm trying to
oh god
other spots i forgot about that oh you
know what i just realized a little flaw
with my with my turret placement what's
that oh us yeah here they come
uh
i'll move quick a lot of dots
that is a lot of dots
oh that's it okay
that's incoming yeah come back to the
door
oh god oh careful being out there uh
whoever that is wade
or mark you're literally standing in my
turret oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah you are yeah way behind you wait
behind you
you guys can come back to the door by
the way and scan i didn't scream you did
we got shooters don't hurt me come here
are you our turrets really hurt
i forgot there was someone shoot oh god
there were shooters where where am you
wait come back to the door there's one
more coming in right there right there
right there is
that's that that's why you can't ping
enemies i forgot because i have to
target them
wait i gotta go all right you need your
turret you need to turn it 27 ammo left
that was a lot of ammo
yeah good job turret probably how many
kills did it get though oh it got like
50.
with my placement i don't even think it
was 50 but yeah i didn't really scan 50
maybe maybe mine they're all dead you
won't be able to tell but they goop so
you can't count them right
now
right on the other side that's
convenient
i told you they're big
yes you they ate their wheaties
but i was busy saying why big one i
don't see it
wait yeah spear boys are gonna have to
go in on that i can't kill that all
right well oh
i think shove it up his ass that's what
it's for
should we double team
oh my god you have to hit them in their
goopy mid mid parts right right it's
their bellies that are the
is that right wait is it i thought i
don't remember i don't remember i gotta
be honest i say we just smack them
i think
dude they one hit from them is not fun
no it's a lot of health
and can two of us take out one of them
it takes all four to kill one
but we can take them all out in one hit
yes
but i still do it
[Music]
you're about to be struck by a vehicle
it's either their belly or their butt or
their head if someone pick one
back back
i'm gonna go for the ass parts all right
wait was it these guys there was a no it
was a different one that had the back
i'm gonna get like heads the
okay i go low you go high and then let's
just agree to shoot the other one
because i don't want to get near it
yeah if it goes if it if it detects
which it might okay
everybody
[Music]
there we'll run
oh god he hates this thing
turn it down
behind what's the separation oh the
tentacles no it was the tentacle it was
the tentacle okay they're good they're
dead they're dead they're not all right
first try nicely done
health that's a lot
that's fine you know why
because you have you have wait who's
lower health i have a health pack uh
uh no there's nothing
on the other side of that door up there
up these ladders there are many
ladders
oh my god
yeah there are just a whole smacker hey
did you guys know that you can hammer
through these doors why you can't we've
had to break through them before i think
haven't we
it's a good way to it's a good way to
enter as though you break down the yeah
oh yeah you could smash them down nobody
hears you it's fine okay they're not
only they're not right on the other side
of the door they're off to the left but
that's
well this room is nothing yeah there's a
lot on that uh flashlight there
bumblebee oh good
oh you're opening the thing i was just
messing around
oh cool i can't see anything
here
yeah
i didn't like that i remember this now
these the dark rooms they're that's
scary
there's one on the right as well yeah
there's two directly in front of us just
two and this sucks yeah and then there's
four
four 12 meters left one 12 meters right
those two should be able to be killed
without triggering the other ones
okay i'm in position on the one on the
left yeah you fellas got it you got it
guys
okay charging now three two one
don't move don't move don't move oh [ __ ]
we got one there's one in the left
there's one in the left there's one
they're all they're all done they're all
gone they're coming back out
okay
jesus
it's fine i'm fine this is fine
hey maybe we should be laying hold on
wait no one coming in one more
two more
there's a dark cello playing there's a
few coming in
i think i think the guns are yeah
clear
all clear
all right first try
that's why the pistol is good the pistol
has a better flashlight on it oh
interesting pistol has like a brighter
flashlight yeah also i just remembered
why glow sticks are actually useful
because we could
yeah
oh yeah i'm getting a weird reading
marcus planker
oh thank you a weird reading that's good
yeah i've never seen this before it's
it's just red circle
it's not on the outside of this door but
it's down the waves a bit i've never
seen it
i don't know what that means
what room are we going to just
we need to get this
this good this is seven
oh i know we need a terminal have we
missed any terminals
lights
yeah we need to we need to query matter
wave projector and figure out where that
might be after what's a matter wave
projector
i don't know what's the matter with you
it's okay i set you up for it i set you
up for it you just got
bobbled there's nothing on the other
side of this door
nothing on the other side
dude's somewhere on the right here yeah
he's over here
oh there's one to the right of me
is there is this a light off moment oh
yeah yeah okay good okay mark can you
get this guy there's one far left of me
here far left yeah i see him
wait and i are gonna swing right maybe
yeah swing right but be careful there's
many
should be able to get these separately
yeah
okay nice we got
about
many all right this corner is clear over
here behind you wayne there was one
right by the staircase yeah i see it now
there's two down there there's two where
that guy's throbbing and there's one up
top on the right somewhere where's the
second guy oh he's there okay okay
oh i hear the guy up to the right oh
this might be the thing where he's up on
a
platform position here okay charging
and go
okay they're down
yeah that one up out of the right
vertical started i don't know where
i don't like the melty sound up the
stairs there are several oh i can get
right here i'm following you
i've got one right never mind uh mark
how many do i have one just one just
this one okay yep i'm gonna i'm gonna
take this one out on my own go for it
okay this room is actually clear after
that it's on the other room
got him yep all right
you know they can't hear you
fire a couple of shots in the air
we really should have used the terminal
before we started
probably
that's a mistake are we a j or a h kind
of gang we don't know nothing on either
of those doors big door has
several that might open up that big room
which is probably the way to go yeah
yeah
lights are off lights off for harambe
one directly to the right
is that a big one to the left that's not
a big one on the left
okay i couldn't tell is it
i don't like the uh the music ambiancing
me i want to hear the clicks and whatnot
i turned my music down don't ambiance me
these guys are spread you should be able
to get them with you mark
yeah around this corner there's two
to the right yeah to the right here
where speed dices going yeah
i hear one throbbing yeah it's over by
us can i get this guy you can get that
guy
cam down buddy one more behind the crate
i think
in between us and wade yeah
those are awake
the one on the far right i did not know
was hey come here you
stinky oh you're smelly and you suck
actually there's nothing on the other
side of this door just a lock
that's a free explorer maybe a terminal
you just wang the lock off right yeah
maybe terminal
oh there might be one to the right
no wait what oh that's an important
piece of information to clarify
what is that sound
okay are we safe or what now okay come
on yeah we're fine
well that's a big deal next time why
don't you bring the scanner bob i
usually used to because i was smart i am
smart about it
no okay
[Music]
that's probably where we need to go but
considering we don't know for sure
should we make a run back to the
terminal that's so
that's so far
uh
negative energy oh on the map i'm sorry
should i make a run back to the terminal
that's it
nothing nothing on
i'm gonna go check out the terminal it's
kind of our way but that's okay because
i'm in a good mood uh i'm not seeing a
turmy
dude as long as you smile everything
goes away no turmeric
yeah these just go back to the rooms
where we were
yeah
i have confidence in us that we can take
this class three alarm maybe class three
is like bad but class 1 is the worst you
know yeah
like golf rules yeah is this like
earthquakes or hurricanes
what kind of system is this i'm going to
turn at the opposite side of this door
then close the door i guess all right
three is pretty middle of the road so
i'm feeling
good i guess yeah that's manageable how
about this three three it was a [ __ ]
baby number anyway so
yeah people say it's a magic number but
who
you want to put a turret outside this
uh face like out here yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
we do have three doors here to worry
about don't we that's okay i can do it
like
they couldn't possibly present all of
them
[Music]
there's a door right here that doesn't
have any turret on it or seafoam so this
might just stand here with my hammer and
just go stay out yes
you can't come in
those circles are going to be outside
this room aren't they
oh
that's why we don't see one door
well that's okay
that door goes to the other doors it's
all good it's all good
we'll find out what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do to get more ready
than you already are oh yeah i miss
myself all right here we go here we go
they're going through the two bar
they're going to that seafoam door
so that's good we can put it outside
this store that would be
terrible
they're coming in
but
easy
okay all right my turret's lighting it
up now they are oh they're through the
door oh the yeah the easy door what easy
door oh my god yeah you're right i
didn't see this i got this i got easy
door i got to use the door
but i want to shoot this shooting calm
down
door through
well he was like half a body by the time
we we actually got there oh can you scan
that door two
[Laughter]
don't shoot in pop pop that's
bad shoot it pop pop
okay you just got
all right
nothing on here we're clear
cold this is definite
is this snow in the air i'm gonna
postulate and not question uh catch one
on your tongue
oh we got i would but i've got the mask
on you know how the mask is for
everybody who wants a big light i do not
want a big light
of the sun
everybody nothing on the other side of
this door either not a security door
what what oh we need everybody who's
do we have friendship in-game
probably from one of our rundowns we
didn't do
go deeper and
be able to track us what
uh wardens
uh things that we did right where we
learned all the important information
about this lore oh
uh
[Laughter]
is it just me or does this guy sound
kind of like mark when he gets too hyper
no come on guys
whenever he bought up brought up bone
broth the first time i feel like this is
exactly what he said
why would you reopen old wounds like
that look i haven't had bone broth in a
while
yeah and you're
arthritic as [ __ ] right now i know are
you a pretty old man yeah it's all gone
to [ __ ] oh hey it's our matter wave
projector hey we found it accidentally
what is this why they have cables in
this rock dude
oh god
oh my god i didn't pick it up
what you said it was me what was that
extraction point extraction goes where
is that we're on the map right it's
coming it's going from this this
direction it's coming from south south
south
we don't have any reason to be here
wait for me extraction boards right here
man it's right here
all right bob look out turns down aimed
right at you burns down in front of your
turret i'm better than you all right no
no that's true it's not going down there
we go oh this is just a
scan
oh this is a slow scan okay
oh we got things
can i drop this by the way
how do i drop you hold that you hold
that bro
okay protect me
oh hell yeah look at you guys go
out
i will uh snipe the big guy 66
here you come
that's a little guy well i don't know
i hear him
all right we got incoming high five
yeah are one of you normies going to
shoot these little shits oh my god
and extraction
oh
man
yeah riddled with bullets at the end but
i'm fine
wait bullets
yeah what do you call the things they
shoot at you
i call them coopers projectiles
fireballs okay
goopers is the more scientific name but
protected this is more vague i guess
i got some clothes in my pants ooh yeah
those are good i didn't get any new
pants i should have gotten new pants
don't know what to tell you wait i
picked up a million bowl boosters why
are there no bull boosters in my bowl
booster tab yeah well you got to pick
them up in
them later what god the shorts pants and
shoes we wear by default are horrible oh
come on they're not that bad oh they're
triggered
oh come on man wearing my dad's shorts
from the [ __ ] 70s
it's like
kind of jogging outfit look at those
tiny ankles and big feet what are these
proportions all right i belong in prison
looking like this
you